ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN IN IT BERMAN BIGELOW LOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN
CHIU CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY
LACKEY LEAH LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA NGUYEN.
O'DONNELL OR SEND PETRIE-NORRIS
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
LOOSE REBAJAS ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE T.
VALIDATORS WE APPROVED VIA
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HONEST. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. MA'AM SPEAKER.
THIS BLESSING TODAY THEN I'M
GONNA DO IS A TRADITIONAL-
LESSENS THE SONG TO SERRANO
SONG- THAT WE'VE SEEN. AND
TODAY IS VERY. IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE'RE ALSO HONORING ALL
THOSE MISSING AND MURDERED
NATIVE AERICAN WOMEN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION IN
HONORING THEIR FAMILIES OF
THOSE THAT STILL ARE LOOKING
FOR CLOSURE. BUT ALSO THIS SONG
IS OFFERING UP TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON ANYTHING THAT
YOU MIGHT BE GOING THROUGH IN
OUR CULTURE. WE CALL JOURNAL
JOURNAL IS THE ALL KNOWING GOD
GOOD GOD THAT WE CONTINUE TO
PRAY TO. AND THIS SONG GOES OUT
TO EVERYONE AND THANK YOU FOR
LETTING US DO THIS BLESSING
HERE ON THIS LEGISLATIVE FLOOR
AND THIS IS THE SERRANO-
BLESSING SOME.
NATIVE AMERICAN LAUNGUAGE BEING SPOKEN
THANK YOU MISTER RAMOS
IT'S ALWAYS MEANINGFUL YOU
BRING IN A LIFE INTO HER
CHAMBERS. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
FROM STANDING AND JOIN FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MANGE. HE LEADS US IN
PLEDGE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES.
ZERO OKAY. INDIVIDUALS YEAH-
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
MOVING TO THE RE OF THE PLAY
DAY'S ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEDNESDAY
APRIL. TWENTY MR FOR SECOND
THAT THE OF THE PRE DAY'S
JOURNAL BE TO WITH. PRESENT AND
PETITION THERE ARE. INTERNET
AND REFERENCE OF WILL DEFERRED
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED TO AND DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS FOR TODAY'S
ABSENCES. FOR DEATH IN THE
FAMILY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN.
MITHRAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTIONS. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE. TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BLOOM GABRIEL
RAMOS AND WALDRON TO SPEAK ON
AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING FILED BY LIVES
ONE THROUGH FIFTY THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME ABILITY
619-701-8612. FIFTY FIVE THREE
FIFTY EIGHT SEVEN FORTY SIX TEN
SIXTY TWO TWELVE TWENTY ONE
FORTY THREE TO TWENTY NINE TO
TWENTY NINE THREE TWENTY THREE
FIVE TWENTY FOUR FIVE.
716-738-5280. NINE NINETY THREE
TEN SEVENTY FOUR ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR ELEVEN NINETY SIX TWELVE
SIXTY TWO TWELVE NINETY THREE
THIRTEEN OH FOUR FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE TO SIXTY FOUR SEVEN
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. 687-253-6580
640-369-6916 NINE FOUR SEVEN
NINETY EIGHT EIGHT EIGHTEEN.
EIGHT THIRTY NINE THIRTY FOUR
TEN FIFTY SEVEN TOLD
731-280-1280. THREE THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN FIFTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR AND SENATE BILL
SEVEN. THANK YOU MOVING TO. OF
ALL BILL THE ADDRESS AND IN
DEEMED ADOPTED MOVING TO BE A
THIRD READING. WE WILL PASS A
RETAINER ITEMS ONE THROUGH
FIFTY FOUR MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
FIFTY FIVE EIGHTY SIX SIXTY
NINE FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS.
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTY NINE WITH THE MOMENTS BY
SOME RELY. IRAQI YOUR
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MAY
SPEAKER THESE MEN AGREE THE
POLES TRAINING FOR FROM SIX MY
TO THREE MONTHS IN A ROW ASK
FOR YOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SEEN HERE NO FOR DEBATE
I THE MATTER WITH OBJECTION
TAKE A BOY VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSING. YOU MAY. ARE A-
OUT OF AND BACK. BY. WE ARE
WILL PASS THIRTEEN AND VIOLENCE
FIFTY SIX THROUGH FIFTY EIGHT
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON ITEM
FIFTY NINE. WILL PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM SIXTY
THROUGH SIXTY TWO MOVING A FILE
ITEM SIXTY THREE AB THREE
NINETY TO THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINETY TWO
BY SOME REMEMBER THIS AREA IN
AN ACT RELATING TO CLINICAL
LABORATORIES. MISTER NAZARIAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER IN PREVIOUS YEARS
I'VE AUTHORED LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD MODERNIZE AND MAKE MORE
EFFICIENT HOW SOME SOURCE
PLASMA PROTEIN IS DERIVED IN
CALIFORNIA MORE SPECIFICALLY
FOR THE PAST FOUR YEARS I'VE
WORKED TIRELESSLY ON A PROGRAM
THAT WOULD ALLOW A TOTAL
PROTEIN TEST USING A DIGITAL
REFRACTIVE METER TO BE
ADMINISTERED BY A TRAINED STAFF
PERSON IN A PLASMA DONATION
CENTER. AB THREE NINETY TWO AS
AMENDED SIMPLY CLARIFIES HOW
STANDARD OPERATING PROCEDURES
ARE DEVELOPED BY PLASMA
DONATION CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
OF AS FOR THE PILOT MY OFFICE
THE SPONSOR AND CDPH ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING ON A WAY TO
ASSESS THE COMPETENCY OF THE
PILOT OPERATORS THAT IS
SUFFICIENT TO THE DEPARTMENT
STANDARDS PLASMA DONATIONS ARE
NECESSARY FOR THE CREATION OF
PLASMA PROTEIN THERAPIES THAT
ARE IMPORTANT TO MANY
INDIVIDUALS WITH RARE CHRONIC
CONDITIONS THIS IS WHY THIS
BILL SUPPORT IS SUPPORTED BY
SUCH A WIDE COALITION OF
ADVOCATES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE ARE. TO OUR
MEMBERS VOTED DESERTED. WHERE
WILL LEAD THE ROLE TALLY THE
VOTE IS THE NINE ZERO MEASURE
PASSED. WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN
AND FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR
THROUGH SEVENTY TWO MOVING A
FILE ITEM SEVENTY. THREE AB A
FIFTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT HOW ARE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN REQUIRE H. TWO A. VISA
EMPLOYERS PROVIDE ALL AGE TO A
FARMWORKERS ON THEIR FIRST DAY
OF WORK WITH WRITTEN NOTICE KEY
STATE AND FEDERAL EMPLOYMENT
RIGHTS INCLUDING INFORMATION
ABOUT THE RISE DURING FEDERAL
AND STATE EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS. LAST YEAR MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND FOREIGN
FARMWORKERS REPORTED BY ROUGHLY
A HUNDRED CALIFORNIA GROWERS
AND FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS
UNDER THE AGE TO A FEDERAL VISA
PROGRAM THIS NUMBER HAS BEEN
INCREASING ANNUALLY A TO A
FARMWORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
LARGELY RECRUITED IN MEXICO AND
ARE TIED TO A SINGLE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYER PROVIDES THEM WITH
HOUSING MEALS AND EXCLUSIVE
TRANSPORTATION TO WORK. SITES
ANY OF THESE WORK HAVE NEVER
BEEN TO. BEFORE NOW THERE'S WE
ENGLISH. THE VERIFY FOR ANY
REASON TO SUBJECT TO. DO WHICH
IS A POWER JUST AS TO. ANY OF
WORK WITH CONDITIONS THERE ARE
SOME TO. AB AB SEVEN SIMPLY
WERE A WILLIAMS FOR. THESE A.
VISA FOR. ON THE FIRST DAY OF
WORK A POP. WRITTEN SUMMARY
CHELATE. TRANSPORTATION RELATED.
HOUSING AND HOW AND SAVE LAWS
SPANISH AND IT BROKE. IN THIS
THE BILL ALSO LIBERTY. TO
DEVELOP A- CAN THIS. AND
OPPOSED ON THE WEB FOR A TO
EMPLOY TO COMPLY THE NOTICE.
EIGHT A PRODUCER CREATES A
SAFER. LEGALLY COMPLY WORKPLACE
FOR H. A FARM. SPECTER
ASTRONAUT VOTE. THANK YOU KALRA.
THE AND HEARING NO TO BE ON
THEM QUICKLY WILL THE- ALL
MEMBERS VOTE TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED OF A. OUR
MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF A. HOME
VOTED OUT OF. REQUIRE. FOR ONE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT THIS
REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE HIGHS FORTY ONE KNOWS
NINETEEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM
SEVENTY FOUR MOVING A FILE ITEM
SEVENTY FIVE EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY TWO THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE EIGHTY TWO
BY FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KAMLAGER AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO MEDICAL MISTER
NAZARIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE MATTER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB THREE EIGHTY TWO
WILL EXTEND THE SUNSET THE FOR
THE STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY GROUP
THAT SUPPORTS THE DEPARTMENT'S
WORK FOR RELATED WORK RELATED
TO THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
SERVICES PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
CARE TO THE STATES SICKEST
CHILDREN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE- CALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. THIRTY THIRD OF THE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE CAL
VOTE I SEE SIX NOW ZERO THE
MEASURE PASS. WE WILL AND
RETAIN AND FILE SEVENTY SIX
MOVIE TO FILE THAT SEVEN AB
FOUR SEVEN FIVE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL. SEVENTY
FIVE BY SOME LOW ACCOLADE TO
LOAN. THIS YOU ARE A- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BENEFIT CALLING THIS
IS A BY MEASURE THAT PER.
POLICE DEPARTMENTS FROM POSTING
MUGSHOT OF PEOPLE OF NOT
VIOLENT CRIME OF THOSE MEDIA
ARE ASK. THANK YOU MISTER.
SEEING NO TO ON THE MAP THAT
THERE WILL OPEN THE ROLE. HOME
MOVED TO THEIR TO. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESIRED. HONG MEMBERS
THEIR. CLERK WILL THE ROLE AND
THE VOTE I FIVE KNOWS THE
MEASURE. WE WILL PASS A RETAIN
AND SEVENTY EIGHT AND SEVENTY
NINE MOVING TO FIVE ITEM A-
EIGHT FOURTEEN FOR FOUR CLERK
OR- ASSEMBLY FORTY FORTY BY
ASSEMBLY LEE ACCOLADE TO FOOD
DELIVERY MR LEE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU SPEAKER
MEMBERS I AM PRESENT TODAY
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FORTY
FOUR TO PROTECT OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND RESTAURANTS
ESPECIALLY THE PANDEMIC SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC
OVER FORTY THOUSAND RESTAURANTS
HAVE CLOSED THEIR DOORS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN THIS PANDEMIC
ECONOMY MANY BUSINESSES HAVE
HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO SERVE
BECOME MORE RELIANT ON THIRD
PARTY FOOD DELIVERY PREFERENCES
REVIVE GIVEN THAT RESTAURANTS
ARE EXISTENTIALLY RELIANT ON
THE SERVICES THERE'S
SIGNIFICANT DISPARITY IN
BARGAINING POWER BETWEEN THE
PLATFORMS RESTAURANTS DESPITE
GROWING COMPETITION IN THE
SPACE THE FOOD DELIVERY
INDUSTRIES PRIMARILY CONTROLLED
BY ONLY FOUR COMPANIES OVER
EATS POSTMATES DOORDASH AND
GRUBHUB WILL COMPRISE 99% OF
SALES AND FOOD. IN THE FOOD
DEALER MARKET IT IS IMPERATIVE
WE PROVIDE THE NECESSARY TOOLS
PROTECTIONS ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES SO THEY ARE ABLE. TO
SURVIVE RECOVER AND THRIVE.
THIS IS WHY WE PASS A FORTY
FORTY FOUR WHICH AND- THAT FOOD
DELIVERY PLATFORM AND ONLINE
DIRECTORIES PROVIDE ACCURATE
BUSINESS INFORMATION.
PROHIBITORY PARTY PLATFORMS AND
CHARGING RESTAURANTS RADICALS I
DO NOT RESULT IN ORDERS AND
REQUIRE DISCLOSURE OF ANY
POSSIBLE FEES. CHARGED TO A
RESTAURANT WHEN PLACING AN
ORDER. I'M HAPPY WORKING WITH
MY SPONSOR THE SILICON VALLEY
CHAMBER COALITION AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU MISTER LEE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER CLERK WILL
OPEN THE- VOTER TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THANK. OUR MEMBERS THEIR VOTE.
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW THOSE I SEE SIX NO ZERO
THEM PASSED WILL PASS THE
RETAIN FILE ITEMS EIGHTY ONE
THREE EIGHTIES MOVE TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN
SIXTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FOUR BY FROM
OF OUR IN A RELATING TO.
RESTAURANT EIGHT ZERO. THANK
YOU MADAM IS MEMBERS THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL TO HELP
UPDATE OUR STATE CRIMINAL LAW
TO REFER THREE. OF THE TWENTY
FOR CENTURY. UNDER CURRENT LAW
COURTS CAN'T PROTECT ORDERS A
PER. WHO HAVE BEEN. OF STALKING
THERE ARE CRIMINAL PANEL FOR
PERPETRATORS TO CONTRACTORS.
DIRECTLY BY TELEPHONE OR BY
USING PHYSICAL MAIL IN
VIOLATION OF PROTECTIVE ORDER
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SIX FOUR
WILL CLOSE A LOOPHOLE BY ADDING
CONTACT OVER SOCIAL MEDIA OR
OTHER ELECTRONIC MEANS. TO THE
LIST OF PROHIBITED. PROHIBITED
FORMS OF ACTIVITY. THIS NOT
ONLY UP THE LOT OF. THE AGE OF
WILL ALSO PROVIDE SOME. WITH MY
FOR TO DESPITE DURING THE
COURSE OF THIS PANDEMIC I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK MYSTERON K. SEEING
IN HEARING NO FURTHER TO ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK OPEN THEIR.
VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
VOTE. HOW MEMBERS VOTED BOTH.
CLERK WILL CALL THE AND VOTE I
SAID KNOWS THE MEASURE PASSES
PASS AND RETAIN AND ITEM NINE
FILE I NINETY AB EIGHT FORTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FORTY VICE
AND WE ROGER AND ACCOLADES
RETIRE. MR RODRIGUEZ ARE BUT
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS ARRIVED
TO PRESENT A BE A FORTY FIVE
WHICH WOULD CREATE A TEMPORARY
REMOVAL PRESUMPTION FOR PUBLIC
SECTOR. FRONTLINE WORKERS THAT.
A COVERT NINETEEN DON'T.
CONTRACT ON THE SO BE. FOR JUST
RETURN. AS WE ARE STILL
DISCOVERING THAT AFFECTS. LONG
HAUL COVER NINETY PATIENT. THIS
BILL IS NECESSARY FINANCE
PROTECT FOR WORKER. SHOULD
THESE AFFECT BE DISABLING.
THESE INDIVIDUALS IN HEALTH
PROVIDERS FIREFIGHTERS MORE
ENFORCEMENT. AND PRIVATE SECTOR
SERVICE JUST TO NAME A FEW
PLEASE JOIN PROTECTING THIS
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
STRICTLY OFF WHEN I VOTE. THANK
YOU MR IVORY. SEARING NO TO ON
THE MATTER THE COLOR WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS TO THEIR- ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF THE.
THIRTY THIRD OF A. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW THE HI
SIX NINE ZERO MEASURE PASSED.
WILL THIRTEEN AND FIVE ITEMS
ONE NINETY TWO FILE ITEM NINE
THREE PURPOSES OF AMEND AB
FORTY NINETY CLERK WILL RE.
ASSEMBLY RULE FOR NINE WITH A
MAN BY ASSEMBLY CHILD MISTER
CHOW YOU ARE A ON THE MENU.
THANK YOU VERY MADAM AND FOR AB
FOURTEEN NINETY REQUIRED THAT
UP. TO THE PUT A ESTADO BY PROP
TWENTY FOUR HAVE EXPERTISE IN
THE AREAS OF PRIVACY TECHNOLOGY
AND CONSUMER RIGHTS THE
AMENDMENTS STRIKE SECTION TWO
FROM THE BILL WHICH ALSO
REMOVED THE OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHOW SEEING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL. IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. ALL OPPOSED SAY NO. THE
AYES IT THE AMENDMENTS WERE
DONE OUT TO PRINT BACK ON.
PASSED THE RETAINER VIOLATE
NINETY THROUGH NINETY SEVEN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NINETY
EIGHT HR FORTY THE CLERK WILL
READ. HOUSE RESOLUTION FORTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS RELATIVE
OF MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS WOMEN AND GIRLS
AWARENESS MONTH. MYSTERON US
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
RESOLUTION THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO
REQUEST YOUR APPROVAL OF H. R.
FORTY. WHICH DESIGNATES MAY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE HAVE
CALIFORNIA'S MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN AND
GIRLS AWARENESS MONTH. AT
TWENTY TWELVE REPORT FROM THE
FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
STATES NEARLY HALF OF ALL
NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN. 46% HAVE
EXPERIENCED. I HAVE EXPERIENCE
RAPE PHYSICAL VIOLENCE OR
STALKING BY AN INTIMATE PARTNER.
ONE IN THREE INDIAN WOMEN WILL
AT SOME POINT IN THEIR LIVES
EXPERIENCE THE VIOLENCE AND
TRAUMA OF THESE OF THESE ISSUES
IF WE DON'T START TO MOVE
FORWARD AND TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES. ON SOME INDIAN
RESERVATIONS NATIVE AMERICAN
WOMEN ARE MURDERED AT A RATE
MORE THAN TEN TIMES THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN MORE THAN
FIVE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
CASES OF MURDERED AND MISSING
INDIGENOUS WOMEN AND GIRLS WERE
REPORTED TO THE NATIONAL CRIME
CENTER. WHAT MAKES THESE
STATISTICS EVEN MORE HORRIFYING
AND SHAMEFUL IS THAT WE KNOW
THESE CASES ARE UNDER REPORTED
A MISCLASSIFIED. LAST YEAR
ALONG WITH YOUR SUPPORT WITH
THE LEGISLATURE WE SUCCESSFULLY
AUTHORED AB THIRTY NINETY NINE
WHICH AUTHORIZES THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO WORK WITH TRIBAL AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
IMPROVE DATA COLLECTION.
COLLABORATION AND AWARENESS TO
BRING CLOSURE TO THESE MISSING
AND MURDERED NATIVE AMERICAN
CASES THAT PLAGUED THE NATION
IN CALIFORNIA. I AM HEARTENED
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE INTERIOR
RECENTLY ESTABLISHED THE
MISSING AND MURDERED UNIT WITH
YEAH AND THE BUREAU OF INDIAN
AFFAIRS OF JUSTICE SERVICES.
THIS HR AND HOUSE RESOLUTION
HERE TODAY WILL ADD WEIGHT A
NEW ENERGY AROUND THE ADVOCACY
THAT HAS BEEN PLAGUED IN INDIAN
COUNTRY FOR SO LONG THAT NOW IS
STARTING TO GAIN TRACTION AND
MOMENTUM. WE NEED TO BE
PERSISTENT AND CONSISTENT AN
INCREASE IN AWARENESS
INCREASING PREVENTIVE MEASURES
IN RESOLVING THESE CASES SO
LOCAL ONES. CAN HAVE CLOSURE IN
THEIR LIVES H. R. FORTY IS A
STEP TOWARDS THESE GOALS THE
FIRST STEP TOWARDS BRINGING
RESOLVED TO ALL THOSE IN INDIAN
COUNTRY AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND I ASK YOU TO BE
OPEN FOR CALL AUTHORS. THANK
YOU MISTER ROBERTS. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE RESOLUTION THE FIRST ROLE
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO VERIFY THAT
THIS IS FOR A CO AUTHOR. ON
VOTED TO THIRD THE IS FOR
AUTHOR. ALL MY VOTED AYE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL THE ROLE HOW
THE VOTE THEY ARE SEVEN THREE
COOPER ON THE RED. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
ON THE REST ALL IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. ALL OPPOSED SAY NO. THE
AYES HAVE IT THE- IS A DOG.
FILE ITEM NINETY NINE AJ ARE
TEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION TEN
BUYERS WILL BE MEMBER CHOI AND
OTHERS ROAD TO REPEL OF KOREA
VETERANS WHO SERVED IN VIETNAM.
IF YOU'RE CHOI ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THE RECKLESS. THANK YOU
SPEAKER THE MEMBERS I'M PLEASED
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY JOINT DON'T
WRESTLE. TEN ON IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARD DOOR RECORD. THE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS OF
KOREAN SOLDIERS TO MADE IN THE
VIETNAM WAR BY URGING CONGRESS.
TO GRANT THOSE- KOREAN VETERANS
BURIAL RIGHTS- ARE IN STATE AND
THE NATIONAL CEMETERIES AS YOU
KNOW. HONORABLY. DISCHARGED THE
VIETNAM. ON THE OTHER. OR THE A
SMALL IS AND THE DEPEND ON THE
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR VERY IN
VETERANS SUCH SO IN EIGHT. THE
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
EXTENDED BURIAL BENEFITS ARE IN
NATIONAL VET OF SENATOR SO TO.
MALL REFUGEES OF WHO SERVE THE
IN AMERICA BACK TO YOUR REAL
YOU NEED- DURING THE OF IT WAR
AND THE WHOLE SUBSEA BE. NOT OF
UNITED STATES SO SAID. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AND STATES THEY
WERE OF KOREA PROVIDED A MAJOR
MILITARY SUPPORT WITH THE
APPROXIMATE. THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND REPUBLICAN OVER
KOREA SOLDIERS SERVING IN
VIETNAM BETWEEN. NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE AND A NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE. READ COREY ARE FORCES.
SUFFERED. TEN THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED TWO INJURED AND THE.
FIVE NINE HUNDRED ZERO NINE
NINE. FIVE THOUSAND NINE KILLED
OFF IN A- DURING THE WAR
APPROXIMATELY THE RATE OKAY S.
UNITED STATES OF COURSE SO HOW
WE DESPITE THE FIGHTING ONE THE
U. S. R. THE PHONE SO DURING
THE VIETNAM WAR WE KOREA.
VETERANS WERE NOT CONSIDERED
ALLEGED FOR BURIAL IN ANY STATE
OR NOT. THE CEMETERY I'VE
REACHED TO BE ASK FOR YOUR
UNABLE TO HOME EIGHTY ON TURN
ONTO ON ON OWN BRIEF FOR ME IN
THIS ORDER OF FALL ALONGSIDE
THE S. SO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR TRYING TWENTY REC ON THE
MATTER THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF A ARE. THE REPUBLIC OF KOREA
THE WHO SERVED IN VIETNAM WAR
AND YUSEF'S WHO BE UNITE STATES
SHOULD BE GIVEN YEAH. TO BE
HONOR VERY TELL NATIONAL. AS
MENTIONED THREE TO THOUSAND
REPUBLICAN KOREA SO JUST IN THE-
WAR BETWEEN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
TO NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE.
WHAT'S THAT AGAIN I RISE IN
SUPPORT AND I ASK MY COLLEAGUES
TO SUPPORT A J. R. TEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU RESTAURANTS MR
VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE MATTER. WE KNOW THE
STATISTICS THAT WERE JUST READ
OUT. BUT THE HUMAN SIDE OF THE
KOREAN. EFFORT IN VIETNAM IS
EVEN MORE IMPRESSIVE. THEY
FOUGHT THEY FOUGHT HARD. AND
WHEN THE KOREANS WENT INTO AN
OPERATIONAL AREA. THE VIETCONG
INDIANA. TOOK A VACATION AND
THE NUMBERS PROVE IT OUT. I
ENCOURAGE A YES VOTE. MATHWORKS
OVER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR CHAMBER. GOOD MORNING
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY AS IS PROUD JOIN
AUTHOR OF AJ ARE TEN WHICH
RECOGNIZES REPUBLICAN OF KOREA
NATIONALS WHO SERVED IN THE
VIETNAM WAR AND BECAME
NATURALIZED CITIZENS OF THE
UNITED STATES. SPECIFICALLY AJ
ARE TEN WOULD URGE CONGRESS AND
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES TO EXTEND BURIAL AND
MA'AM MORIAL BENEFITS AT
NATIONAL CEMETERIES TO THE
KOREAN AMERICANS WHO SERVED
WITH US IN THE VIETNAM WAR. THE
REPUBLIC OF KOREA PROVIDED MORE
MILITARY SUPPORT TO THE UNITED
STATES DURING THE MEET VIETNAM
WAR THAN ANY OTHER L. A. WHICH
IS APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THOUSAND SOLDIERS.
SERVING BETWEEN NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE AND NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE. ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
KOREANS AMERICANS LIVED IN THE
UNITED STATES. APPROXIMATELY
THREE THOUSAND ARE VETERANS OF
THE VIETNAM WAR WHO ARE
NATURALIZED CITIZENS OF THE
UNITED STATES CALIFORNIA HAS
THE HIGHEST POPULATION OF
KOREAN AMERICANS. IN THE
COUNTRY AND IN MY DISTRICT WE
ARE PROUD TO HAVE THE SECOND
LARGEST KOREAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY IN OUR STATE. PLEASE
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH OUR
KOREAN AMERICAN VETERANS WHO
SERVE SIDE BY SIDE WITH US IN
VIETNAM BY SUPPORTING AJ ARE
TEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISPRONOUNCES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS WAS GOING TO
SPEAK ON THIS BUT I WAS TALKING
TO SOMEBODY ON THE FLOOR- CAME
TO MY ATTENTION OF WHAT WHY DO
WE NEED THIS BILL. IN ITS VERY
SIMPLE THIS PAYS HOMMAGE IN
RESPECT. IN KEEPS TRUE TO
PROMISES THAT WERE MADE DURING
A TIME OF WAR. WHEN WE ASK FOR
HELP WHEN HELP WAS ASKED OF US
TO FIGHT. THESE MEN AND WOMEN
STOOD WITH US THEY STOOD ON THE
LINE FOR THE SHED BLOOD THE
SWEAT. TEARS EVERYTHING WITH US
IN THIS SHOWS THAT WE'RE
KEEPING CHIU DUE TO OUR
PROMISES THERE AND ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER MATHIS. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISTER TROY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I WOULD LIKE
TO. ASK IS BECAUSE OPEN UP A
FOUR COLDWELL WAS SO ON THIS
BILL AND YOU ARE TO BE A- THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHOI THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR FOR
AUTHOR. ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
ABOUT THIS IS FOR AUTHORS ON
THE RED. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IT
THIS IS FOR OP ON THE
RESOLUTION. WHERE WHERE CLOSE
THE ROLE IN CALLIE THE THERE
ARE THREE HOW ARE ON THE
RESOLUTION THE WILL THE ROLE
FOR A VOTE ON THE REST. ALL MY
VOTE VERY TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE TO THEIR OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW THE
VOTES. SAID TWO THE RESOLUTION
A TO. A PAST EVENT ON FILE ITEM
ONE HUNDRED MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE NO ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY
BY SIMPLY LOW AND OTHERS
ACRYLATE TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THIS THOUGH YOU ARE. THANK YOU
VERY OF AN ISSUE CURRENT CALL.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOR THIRD TWO
WOULD ELIMINATE CALVARY COLLEGE
THIS IS A WASTE OF. DOLLARS HAS
RECEIVED FIVE SUPPORT AMHERST
ASK. THANK YOU MAY LOW- MISTER
READING ARE. THANK YOU MAN
SPEAKER. MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
ASSEMBLY OF THEM LOW FOR
INTRODUCE THIS BILL AND I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY TWO AS CHAIR OF THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE I'VE
CALLED FOR AN AUDIT OF THE CALL
BRIGHT COLLEGE. ALTHOUGH THE
ORIGINAL INTENT AND MISSION OF
CALIBRATORS NOBLE IT IS
STRUGGLE WITH NUMEROUS ISSUES
SINCE ITS INCEPTION THAT WE CAN
NO LONGER IGNORE. THESE
PROBLEMS AND COLLUDED VERY HIGH
COST PER STUDENT AN UNCREDITED
PROGRAMS. EVEN THE ONLINE
PLATFORM OF COBB RIGHT WHICH
CREATES ACCESSIBILITY FOR
WORKING STUDENTS IS NOT UNIQUE.
AS EXISTING COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE DEMONSTRATED IN THE PAST
YEAR. WELL CALIBRATED STRUGGLED
TO ISSUE THIRTY FIVE
CREDENTIALS AND CURRENTLY
ENROLLED FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR STUDENTS THE OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE SHOWN
THEIR ABILITY TO ADAPT EXPAND.
AND SERVE TWO POINT ONE MILLION
STUDENTS EVEN IN A PANDEMIC.
ELIMINATING CAL RIGHT COLLEGE
WOULD ENABLE THE STATE TO RE
DIRECT NEARLY A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
OTHER PROGRAMS IN OTHER HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS. HAVING
GRADUATED FEW STUDENTS WHILE
TAKING AWAY RESOURCES FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CALIBRATE IS
SIMPLY NOT HELPING OUR
STUDENTS. FOR THESE REASONS I
SUPPORT A. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY
TWO. THANK YOU MISTER AND IN S.
SAYING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MR LOW
WOULD YOU LIKE THOSE THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS OF
A- ALL MEMBERS VOTED OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AMERICA.
WHERE WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY KNOWS
THERE THE MEASURE PASSES. WILL
AND ON FILE ITEMS ONE OR TWO
AND OR THREE MOVING TO BUY ITEM
ONE FOUR EIGHT FIFTY THIRTY SO
THE FIRST RAIN ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTY SO BY MEMBER LOW AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
MASSAGE THE- HELLO YOU ARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES THIS IS
THE SUNSET BILL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL WE'RE WORKING TO
ADDRESS A NUMBER OF FORMS OVER
A PERIOD OF TIME AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR LOW SEEING AND HEARING
NO. THIS NEW IN EUROPE A MATTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU- MADAMS. I
RISE AND- OF. A ONE FIVE THREE.
I WANT TO FIRST THANK THE OFF
IN THE COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE. HAVING
SERVE ON THIS COUNCIL ON THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL. THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT ISSUES THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED. SO I'M
HOPEFUL AND THAT I WILLBE ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE. AS
YOU CONTINUE YOUR EFFORTS IN
THE NECESSARY REFORM OF THIS
COUNCIL TO MAKE ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY. TRANSPARENCY
PROTECTING THE LICENSEE AND THE
PUBLIC AND THAT IT IS A FAIR
PROCESS. WILL BE WAS ONE OF IT
WILL BE THAT THOSE REFORMS THAT
WE WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO. AGAIN
I RISE IN SUPPORT I ASK MY
COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER RANDALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MR LOW TO EXPOSE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. OF A-
ALL MEMBERS VOTED ARE TO VOTE.
OUR MEMBERS VERY VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING
VOTE I SEVENTY NEWS HERE THE
MEASURE. WILL BE AND RETAIN A
PILOT ONE OF. THROUGH ONE
THIRTEEN MOVING BACK UP IN FILE
ORDER TO FILE ITEM. FIFTY NINE
EIGHTY THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO AND
OTHER PERSON AT RELATING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. MYSTERY ARE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WHICH
CLARIFIES THAT THE NINETY DAYS
EMPLOYERS HAVE TO CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION. SHOULD BE
WORKING DAYS EXCLUDING WEEKENDS
AND HOLIDAYS. EXISTING LAW
ADDRESSES TIME LIMITS FOR
INVESTIGATIONS BUT AFTER NINETY
DAYS DISTRICTS ARE FORCED TO
BRING BACK EMPLOYEES WHO SHOULD
REMAIN ON THE BASED ON THE
NATURE. AND STATUS OF THE
ALLEGATIONS. FOR THAT REASON
THE BILL ALSO ALLOWS THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE TIME TO BE
EXTENDED NO MORE THAN THIRTY
DAYS OF BOTH THE EMPLOYER AND
THE EMPLOYEE ARE IN AGREEMENT.
IN THE WAKE OF COVER NINETEEN A
VAST MAJORITY OF EMPLOYEES
SHIFTED TO REMOTE WORK MAKING
IT DIFFICULT FOR EMPLOYERS TO
COMPETE. COMPLETE THOROUGH
INVESTIGATIONS THE COMPLEXITY
OF GATHERING INFORMATION
CONDUCTING INTERVIEWS AND
COMPILING INFORMATION HAS BEEN
FURTHER EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC. THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND IT PROVIDES MUCH
NEEDED RELIEF DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIMES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS CARILLO. SEEING AND- NO
FURTHER ON THE MATTER THE WILL
OPEN THEIR- VERITABLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. OUR
MEMBERS VOTED AYE VOTE. WHERE
WILL THE ROLE AND HOW THE I.
SEVENTY KNOWS THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
THE CAN CALENDAR. ON THE A
CONFINED CAL ARE FOR ITEM ONE
CAN ONE IN FIFTIES ONE FIFTY A-
THERE ARE. ON TODAY'S HOW
BEFORE VOTE WE WILL FIRST TAKE
UP THE RATHER. FOR PURPOSES OF
ADDING HOW AUTHORS THE CLERK
READ THE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY COURAGE
SEVENTY ONE BY MEMBER VIA ABOUT
TO FOR DAY SENATE KICKER
RESOLUTION TO CENTER BURKE AND
OTHER RELATIVE BLACK A MORE
MARC ANTHONY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWENTY ONE BY SO
RUBIO AND OTHER RELATIVE TO
JUST WITH BETTER GINSBURG DAY.
WHERE WELL NOW OPEN THE ROLE.
COOPER TO THESE RED. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED ABOUT THIS IS FOR
OP. ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERITABLE
THIS IS FOR AUTHORS TO THE
RESOLUTION ON CONSENT. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO GO.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW YOU THAT THEY ARE SEVEN
FOUR AUTHOR. WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO A VOTE ON THE CONTENT HOW
FIVE ALLIED AND ONE SEVENTY
THROUGH ONE EIGHT. THIS ANY
MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVING ITEM
FOR THE CAN CAL. SEEING AND
HEARING THE WILL READ SECOND
EIGHT COUNT. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
BY SUMMER SALAS AND OTHERS AND
ACT RELATING TO GET. WELL OPEN
THE WRONG. HOME MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MY VOTED
TO VERIFY. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
THIRD OF THE. BURKE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES I
IT THE CLERK WILL READ OR I ON
THE CONTRACT ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
THIRTY NINE SEVENTY SIX YES
ASSEMBLY BILL. TWO EIGHTY THREE
NINE SEVEN SIX ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE NOW FIVE SEVEN SIX ZERO
SOME BILL. THREE EIGHT SEVENTY
SIX ZERO SOME PEOPLE FOR FORTY
FOUR I SEVENTY SIX ZERO ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY. SEVENTY
SIX ASSEMBLY SO TWO I SIX KNOWS
THERE ARE SOME BILL. FOUR FOUR
SEVENTY SIX ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETY TWO I SEVENTY AND IS
THERE SOME BEFORE THAT FOUR
THANK SIX ZERO ZERO ASSEMBLY
RULE FOR TWENTY WITH HER. FIVE
SEVEN SIX NOW IS THERE ON YOUR
I. I SEVENTY SIX ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX SEVENTY FOUR SEVENTY
SIX NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY EIGHTEEN FIVE SEVENTY
SIX ZERO ZERO SEMINAL SEVEN
FORTY NINE SEVENTY SIX SO WE
REALLY TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY SIX
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SIXTY NINE
SEVENTY SIX ZERO ZERO SAN
MIDDLETON THIRTY ONE FIVE
SEVEN. ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN TWELVE WITH URGENCY I
SEVENTY SIX DAYS EARLIER I
SEVENTY SIX ZERO THE MEASURE
WAS A MODEL OF THE FORTY EIGHT
I SEVENTY SIX ZERO ZERO SOME
PEOPLE TWELVE TWENTY TWO I
SEVENTY SIX ZERO ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SIX ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTINO NINE SEVENTY SIX. SOME
PEOPLE FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY SIX ZERO ZERO ASSEMBLY
GO FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN FIVE
SEVENTY SIX THERE ARE SOME REAL
FIFTEEN FORTY ONE I SEVENTY SIX
AS THERE ARE SOME AGO FIFTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX. SOME
LEGAL THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN I
SEVENTY SIX ZERO ZERO ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
ONE I. SEVENTY SIX NEAR ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY NINETY TWO
SEVENTY SIX AS THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE THIRTEEN FOURTEEN BY
SEVENTY SIX. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX ZERO
ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY NINETY
ONE I SEVENTY SIX ZERO ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION TWELVE I
SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO. FIVE
SEVEN SIX ZERO INCIDENT
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION. TWENTY
ONE FIVE SEVEN SIX ZERO.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE COURT
CALL WILL NOW BE LIFTED AND WE
WILL TO THE- ANNOUNCED IN. IN
MEMORY. PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE CONVERSE. OFF THE.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR. MR GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I RISE TODAY TO REQUEST THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF LIEU
CHATMAN WHO PASSED AWAY ON
APRIL EIGHTH AT THE AGE OF
NINETY NINE- IS A TRULY
REMARKABLE HUMAN BEING. A
HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR WHO ENDURED
UNIMAGINABLE CRUELTY AND YET
FACE LIFE WITH RELENTLESS
OPTIMISM AND KINDNESS.
FITTINGLY LOU PASSED AWAY ON
THE SAME DAY THAT WE OBSERVE
YOM HASHOAH HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY HERE ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. LOU IS BORN IN
POLAND IN NINETEEN TWENTY TWO
INTO A LOVING AND VIBRANT
JEWISH FAMILY. HE MARRIED HIS
CHILDHOOD SWEETHEART DOROTHY IN
THE GHETTO AND RANDOM IN
NINETEEN FORTY TWO SHORTLY
BEFORE THE **** INVASION
CHANGED THEIR LIVES FOREVER.
LOU AND DOROTHY WERE SEPARATED
AND ADORED EXTRAORDINARY
BRUTALITY. AGAINST ALL ODDS
BOTH SURVIVED THE SHOAH DESPITE
BEING SENT TO THE TORIES STAFF
CAMP AT AUSCHWITZ. THEY LOST
MOST OF THEIR FRIENDS AND
FAMILY BUT WERE MIRACULOUSLY
REUNITED IN NINETEEN FORTY SIX
AT A REFUGEE CAMP AND STOOD
GUARD GERMANY. THEY THEN
EMIGRATED TO YOUNGSTOWN OHIO
AND STARTED A FAMILY AND A NEW
LIFE TOGETHER IN THE UNITED
STATES. THIS IS A BIT JERRY SO
APTLY NOTES LOU WAS AN
INSPIRATION TO EVERYONE WHO MET
HIM. AND A HERO TO ALL WHO ARE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO KNOW HIM. HE
EXUDED POSITIVITY STRENGTH AND
HUMOR DESPITE THE HARDSHIPS HE
SUFFERED EARLY IN LIFE. HE
LOVES SINGING CELEBRATING THE
JEWISH HOLIDAYS AND ABOVE ALL
ELSE HIS FAMILY. LUIS
PASSIONATE ABOUT EDUCATING
YOUNG PEOPLE ABOUT THE
HOLOCAUST TO ENSURE THAT THE
JEWISH PEOPLE NEVER AGAIN
EXPERIENCED GENOCIDE. HIS
STRENGTH AND SPIRIT WERE
UNMATCHED AND HE WILL NEVER BE
FORGOTTEN. IN REFLECTING ON LOU
THE OTHER DAY I WAS REMINDED OF
THE TIME WE WERE PRIVILEGED TO
CELEBRATE PASSOVER WITH HIM.
WERE YOU SURPRISED AND
DELIGHTED OUR FAMILY WITH HIS
POWERFUL RENDITION. OF DOG NOT
KAIMAL PHANTOM OF JEWISH
RESISTANCE FIGHTERS TO THE ****
IN THAT MOMENT. AS HE WAS
DURING MUCH OF HIS LIFE LOU WAS
THE LIVING EMBODIMENT OF THE
EXTRAORDINARY RESILIENCE OF THE
JEWISH PEOPLE. STRONG PROUD
POSITIVE FULL OF LIFE AND HOPE
AND VIGOR AND COMMITTED TO
TEACHING ABOUT THE HORRORS OF
GENOCIDE IN HOPES THEY WOULD
NEVER BE REPEATED. LOU'S LEGACY
ALSO INCLUDES AN EXTRAORDINARY
FAMILY THAT HAS CONTINUED TO
TEACH AND INSPIRE AND HEAL THE
WORLD. INCLUDING HIS CHILDREN
MARVIN CHATMAN WHO HAS SO ABLY
LED THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION OF LOS ANGELES FOR
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS. AND HIS
DAUGHTER TESS WILL COUGH WHO IS
MENTORED GENERATIONS OF
STUDENTS AS A BELOVED GUIDANCE
COUNSELOR AT OAK PARK HIGH
SCHOOL. IN ADDITION TO HIS
CHILDREN LUIS MOURNED BY HIS
SIX GIVE GRANDCHILDREN AND
EIGHT GRAND GREAT GRAND
CHILDREN. LUCHON WILL BE DEEPLY
MISSED BUT HIS MEMORY WILL BE A
BLESSING TO HIS FAMILY OUR
COMMUNITY AND TO THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
SPECIALLY REQUESTED WE ARE
JOINED TODAY IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL. ZERO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR OTHER
GERMAN MEMORIES WILL. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
REQUEST THAT WE IN TURN IN
MEMORY OF A BELOVED LEADER AND
PILLAR OF OUR COMMUNITY MAWKISH
ALLIES WHO PASSED AWAY THIS
PAST SHABBAT APRIL THIRTIETH.
AT THE AGE OF NINETY TWO. AS SO
MANY HAVE NOTED IN RECENT DAYS
MARKLE WAS KNOWN THROUGHOUT OUR
COMMUNITY PARTICULARLY AT
VALLEY BETH SHALOM MY
SYNAGOGUE. FOR HER WISDOM HER
COMPASSION AND HER
EXTRAORDINARY KINDNESS. SHE WAS
A PARTNER IN EVERY SENSE OF THE
WORD TO RABBI HAROLD M. CHEL
WEISS OF BLESSED MEMORY. WHO
LED VVS FOR MANY YEARS AND WAS
WIDELY RECOGNIZED AS ONE OF THE
GREAT AMERICAN RABBIS THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY. AS RABBI
CHAU I SHARED WITH MANY IN OUR
COMMUNITY HE NEVER DELIVERED A
SERMON. PUBLISHED AN ARTICLE OR
PARKED ON AN INITIATIVE WITHOUT
SEEKING FEEDBACK AND GUIDANCE
FROM MONICA HIS ULTIMATE
CREATIVE AND INTELLECTUAL
PARTNER. SHE WAS A BRILLIANT
TEACHER AND A POWERFUL SPEAKER
AND IN THE BEAUTIFUL WORDS OF
COMMUNITY LEADER JANICE CAMERA
RUSNAK. A PIONEERING EXAMPLE OF
HOW TO BE A MORE FEMINIST
VERSION OF A RIBBON EXPOUNDS.
BORN AND RAISED IN A LARGE
LOVING IMMIGRANT FAMILY IN NEW
YORK CITY MARK MALCOLM AT
HERALD AT A DANCE WHEN SHE WAS
SEVENTEEN. AND THEY MARRIED A
YEAR LATER. AFTER MOVING TO
CALIFORNIA SHE COMPLETED HER
MASTER'S DEGREE IN ENGLISH
LITERATURE AT UC BERKELEY. AND
LATER EMBARKED UPON A CAREER AS
AN INSTRUCTOR AT SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY STATE COLLEGE. BETTER
KNOWN TODAY AS THE SUN. LATER
IN LIFE SHE TURNED TO
PSYCHOLOGY COMPLETING AN
INTERNSHIP AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE HOSPITAL CAMARENA. AND
LAUNCHING A CAREER AS A SOUGHT
AFTER THERAPIST IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE. THROUGHOUT ALL THIS
MARKET WAS PASSIONATE ABOUT
SOCIAL JUSTICE INTO GOING ALONG.
AS OUR RABBIS OBSERVE SHE LIVED
AND TAUGHT GODLINESS AND
DEMANDED THAT WE RAISE OUR
EXPECTATIONS OF OURSELVES OUR
TRADITION AND OUR COMMUNITY.
SHE REPRESENTED A WAY OF LIVING
THAT TESTIFIES TO THE POTENTIAL
OF HUMAN BEINGS TO BUILD THE
WORLD'S OF COMPASSION
GENEROSITY AND KINDNESS. WHEN
SHE SPOKE HER WORDS WERE FILLED
WITH URGENCY AND PASSION AND
SHE MODEL FOR OUR COMMUNITY AND
INSPIRING VISION OF JEWISH LIFE
IN FUSED WITH ETHICAL ACTION.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY LOVING
FAMILY THAT INCLUDES HER
CHILDREN LISA SASFIN ETAN AS
WELL HER HER SEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN AND THREE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. MOCHA CHAU ICE
WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED. BUT HER
MEMORY WILL BE A BLESSING FOR
HER FAMILY OUR COMMUNITY AND
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURNED TODAY
IN HER MEMORY. THANK YOU MR
GABRIEL MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF PHILANTHROPIST
ELI BRODE. MR BRODE WAS BORN ON
JUNE SIXTH NINETEEN THIRTY
THREE IN THE BRONX TO JEWISH
LITHIA LITHUANIAN IMMIGRANT
PARENTS. AND RAISED IN MICHIGAN
HIS FATHER MADE A LIVING BY
PAINTING HOMES AND HIS MOTHER
WAS A SEAMSTRESS. ROAD WORKERS
WAY THROUGH COLLEGE BY WORKING
ODD JOBS LIKE DOOR TO DOOR
SALES HE GRADUATED FROM
MICHIGAN STATE UNIVERSITY IN
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR AND BECAME
THE YOUNGEST PERSON IN THE
STATE OF MICHIGAN TO BECOME A
CPA. WHILE DOING ACCOUNTING FOR
HIS BROTHER IN LAW'S HOME
BUILDING BUSINESS THE TWO BEGAN
A PARTNERSHIP FOUNDING KAUFMAN
AND BRODE. IN NINETEEN FIFTY
SIX. BY THE END OF THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES THE COMPANY HAD REACHED
PEAK SUCCESS. KAUFMAN AND BRODE
WAS THE FIRST HOME BUILDER
LISTED ON THE NEW YORK STOCK
EXCHANGE. ROAD LEFT THE COMPANY
AND IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE HE
BOUGHT A FAMILY OWNED INSURANCE
COMPANY. WHICH HE BUILT UP OVER
TWO DECADES BEFORE SELLING THE
BUSINESS IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT FOR NEARLY EIGHTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS. THEN AT THE
PEAK OF WEALTH AND SUCCESS.
ROAD TURNED HIS ATTENTION AND
HIS ENERGY TOWARDS PHILANTHROPY
AND THE ARTS. IT WOULD BE
IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME TO ENUMERATE
THE MANY WAYS THAT THE LIBRO
HEAD CONTRIB HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
THE FABRIC OF THE LOS ANGELES
LANDSCAPE. FOR EXAMPLE THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY MUSEUM OF ART
WHICH IS IN MY DISTRICT IS A
RENOWNED LA CULTURAL
INSTITUTION THAT WOULD NEVER
HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE. WITHOUT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS BOTH MONETARILY
AND OF OUR- FROM ELI BRODE.
FROM SCHOOLS AND POLITICS TO
OUR MUSEUMS AND MUSICALES
BROACHED PHILANTHROPIC
FINGERPRINTS ARE VISIBLE. E.
LIBRO TO LIVE LOS ANGELES AND
HE MADE IT BOTH HIS HOME AND
HIS PASSION. THE FOUNDING
DIRECTOR OF THE BROAD MUSEUM
JOANNE HAYLER WAS QUOTED AS
SAYING. VERY FEW IN LA'S
HISTORY WHO HAVE COME REMOTELY
CLOSE TO BE BROAD SENSE OF DUTY
AND HIS WILLINGNESS TO PUT HIS
OWN TIME AND EFFORT PRESSING
HIS POLITICAL CONNECTIONS
STRONG ARMING BUSINESS PEERS
AND STEPPING UP FOR THE ARTS.
THE WAY HE DID. E. LIBRO PASSED
AWAY LAST WEEKEND ON APRIL
THIRTIETH AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY
SEVEN. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE OF SIXTY SEVEN YEARS EDITH
EDIE ROAD AND THEIR TWO SONS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN E. LIBROS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR BERMAN. MISTER
ROBERTS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER- WANT
TO THANK YOU AND TODAY I RISE
TO REQUEST THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED TODAY IN THE MEMORY
OF PATRICK MURPHY JUNIOR. WHO
PASSED AWAY ON APRIL TWENTY
FIRST HE WAS A LIFELONG
RESIDENT OF THE PECHANGA INDIAN
RESERVATION OF THE LOOSE ANY OF
PEOPLE. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE IRENE MURPHY DAUGHTER
NATASHA MENDOZA SONS MICHAEL
MURPHY AND PATRICK- PJ MURPHY.
HIS PARENTS PATRICK MURPHY
SENIOR. HIS SISTER ROSALYN
TENSELY AND TWO GRANDCHILDREN
NICHOLAS AND ERIC MENDOZA.
PATRICK WAS A PILLAR NOT JUST
OF TRIBAL ENTERPRISES IN TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY THAT RESULTED IN
HUNDREDS OF JOBS AND
SIGNIFICANT TRAVEL RESOURCES
BUT ALSO A PILLAR OF THE
COMMUNITY. AND IT WAS ALSO A
CULTURAL PERSON AND ENJOYED
SINGING TRADITIONAL SONGS OF
HIS PEOPLE. HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL
IN DEVELOPMENT AND CONSTRUCTION
OF THE ORIGINAL PECHANGA
ENTERTAINMENT CENTER. THE
PERMANENT PECHANGA RESORT
CASINO THE GAS STATION THE MINI
MART AND RV RESORT JUST TO NAME
A FEW. PATRICK FOUGHT TO
PROTECT TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY AND
THE ADVANCEMENT OF TRIBAL
RIGHTS FOR ALMOST A DECADE HE
SERVED AS SECRETARY OF THE
TRIBAL ALLIANCE OF SOVEREIGN
INDIAN NATIONS ARE LEADING
INTER GOVERNMENTAL ASSOCIATION
A TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I'VE KNOWN
PATRICK MURPHY JUNIOR FOR MANY
YEARS AND ONE STORY THAT WE
SHARE IS A ONE ALL THESE
NEGOTIATIONS FOR COMPACT BEFORE
WE EVEN HAVE THE CONTACTS WERE
WE ARE NOW. WE ALL WENT TO
WASHINGTON DC TO PUSH FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR TO MOVE
FORWARD ON BAD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS WE WENT TO THEN
SECRETARY BRUCE BABBITT'S
OFFICE AND WE MET WITH THEN
UNDERSECRETARY OF GARAMENDI AND
WE PUSHED TOGETHER- TO INVOKE
THE BAD FAITH NEGOTIATIONS HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
PATRICK WAS THERE WITH US AND
THAT DAY CHANGED THE VISION AND
CHANGE THE COURSE FOR INDIAN
COUNTRY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE WE TOOK NO
FOR AN ANSWER AND MANY OF US
THAT WERE THERE WE SAT IN THAT
ROOM AND PATRICK. MURPHY JUNIOR
WAS ONE OF THOSE. THAT WHEN WE
TALKED ABOUT BEING ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD OUR OWN DESTINIES IN
INDIAN COUNTRY AND BUILD ON OUR
SOVEREIGNTY. BY SITTING IN THAT
ROOM FOR OVER TWO AND A HALF
HOURS TAKING NO FOR AN ANSWER
STARTED TO MOVE THEY HEARINGS A
STARTED TAKE PLACE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ON COMPACTS THAT
ULTIMATELY LED TO THE PASSAGE
OF PROPOSITION FIVE. IN
PROPOSITION ONE NAY WHICH
AUTHORIZED TRIBAL GAMING IN THE
STATE AND PLAYED A KEY ROLE TO
ADVANCE LEGISLATION TO
DISTRIBUTE MONEYS FROM THE
INDIAN GAMING SPECIAL JUST IN
FRONT TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES
SHARING BACK TO OUR COMMUNITIES
PATRICK WAS A BIG PILLAR. IN A
BIG PERSON IN INDIAN COUNTRY
THAT PAVE THE WAY. AND THROUGH
HIS LEADERSHIP THROUGH HIS
LEADERSHIP MANY TRIBES ENJOY
THOSE COMPACTS THAT WE SEE
TODAY ON THIS LEGISLATIVE
FLOOR. HE KATIE CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT THE WELL BEING OF ALL IS
SUPPORTED SEVERAL NONPROFITS IN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY. FOR ALMOST
TEN YEARS HE SERVED AS A
VOLUNTEER FIREFIGHTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION.
LAST YEAR PATRICK RECEIVED THE
LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT AWARD FROM
THE TEMECULA VALLEY CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE FOR HIS MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE GREATER TO
MACULAR VALLEY. WE OFFER OUR
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY AND
TO THE PECHANGA TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT AND TO THE LISTEN
YOU PEOPLE FOR THIS GREAT LOSS
IN INDIAN COUNTRY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
MYSTERONS MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THING THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER. R. I ALSO RISE
TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF PATRICK MURPHY WHO'S
OUR FRIEND. AFTER ALL THAT OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM HIGHLAND
MENTIONED IT'S OBVIOUS THAT
PATRICK MURPHY SERVICE HAS BEEN
INVALUABLE TO THE PECHANGA.
BAND OF THE SAME NEW INDIANS
AND THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES
IN MY DISTRICT. MISTER MURPHY
SPENT NEARLY TWO DECADES IN THE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION FEEL
HE WORKED HIS WAY FROM AN ENTRY
LEVEL POSITION TO PROJECT
MANAGEMENT AND BROUGHT THAT
INCREDIBLE WORK ETHIC AND
INSIGHT TO THE PECHANGA TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT. DURING PATRICK'S
TENURE ON THE PECHANGA
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION BOARD.
PRACHANDA'S WORKFORCE GROUP
FROM ONLY A HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES TO MORE THAN SIX
THOUSAND MAKING IT ONE OF THE
TOP FIVE LARGEST PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
PATRICK'S CONTRIBUTION TO
PROTECTING TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY
AND THE ADVANCEMENT OF TRIBAL
RIGHTS EXTENDS BEYOND PECHANGA
THOSE ARE COLLEAGUES WITH
MENTIONED. AS WELL AS ALSO WAS
MENTIONED PATRICK PLAYED AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN BUILDING A
COALITION OF LOCAL AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ADVANCE POLICIES
TO MAKE SURE THAT LOCAL
COMMUNITIES RECEIVE FUNDING.
FROM THE INDIAN GAMING SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND. IN ADDITION
TO ALL HE DID FOR TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS. AFTER EXTENDED
CATION TO SERVING HIS COMMUNITY
WAS EXEMPLIFIED IN HIS
INVOLVEMENT IN NON PROFITS AND
HIS DECADES OF VOLUNTEER
FIREFIGHTERS EXPERIENCE. BUT
ANYONE WHO KNEW HIM COULD
RECOGNIZE HIS ENERGY AND HIS
ENTHUSIASM HE ALWAYS HAD A
SMILE ON HIS FACE AND WAS READY
TO ROLL UP HIS SLEEVES AND DIG
IN. MEMBERS TODAY WE CELEBRATE
PATRICK MURPHY'S REMARKABLE
LEGACY AND ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS WALDRON
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAME
FOR THE DEATH TO BE PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS
RICHARD IN MEMORY WILL BE READ.
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS SESSION SCHEDULES
AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY MAY SEVENTH
NO FLOOR SESSION- CHECK IN
SESSION MONDAY MAY TENTH FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
TO RETAIN DAHLE MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
THIS GARCIA MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
MAY TENTH AT ONE PM.
FILE ITEM
NUMBER. ONE ZERO ONE. BILL
NUMBER FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO
GIPSON FROM I DO NOT VOTING.
BURKE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
THIRTY TWO I TO NOT VOTING.